out lighter the Major League Baseball
Network kind enough to join us before he
takes a flight back home
the Astros won the World Series because
while I'm gonna
that's a good question I'm gonna say
that the three true outcomes of baseball
really was very evident during this
World Series DP what they broke the
homerun record you boatload of
strikeouts
there were only four stolen bases
throughout the entire World Series and I
think now this is no knock on Dave
Roberts but we are in a absolute
sabermetric world of baseball and I
think it's the decisions for each
respective manager to hold starters I
think ultimately burnt out guys you
can't lay on and lean on the same two or
three guys even though this is becoming
a reliever centric world of baseball as
we're watching this evolve managers
can't wait to pull starters to get to a
middle reliever to start the matchups
and eventually when you get to games
five six and seven you're burning and
leaning on a guy like a Brandon Morrow
fits every game except game for the LCS
and postseason yeah you bet you're going
to be tired and I think you saw that and
ultimately and then believe it or not
because the Dodgers actually had the
better Boca and certainly with Kenley
Jansen accurate down a guy like Brad
peacock and Charlie Morton where the
difference in this world series were the
Dodgers out managed or did the Dodgers
over managed I would say I love Dave
Roberts I'm not gonna say out menace III
think maybe there was some over managing
when you're taking guys out and they get
their give up their first hit that
happens to be a home run in the sixth
inning and then you say that you were
trying to extend them and if he didn't
have a no-hitter ala Alex wood in his
start I would have taken him out after
five innings
it just for many DP that blows my mind
as a starting pitcher much of my career
and a guy like Bobby Valentine have kept
me in for 143 pitches in the ninth
inning in the 2000 World Series when I
was with the Mets against the Yankees
ultimately we're losing and we're
talking about starters
being taken out with 60 70 80 pitches
and they only gave up one run I don't
understand it and then therefore we're
watching a lot of middle reliever guy
matchup stuff to eventually get to your
setup guy closer so I think that were a
couple starts and we saw the reaction of
rich Owen a couple of this starts
getting pulled out early announce would
and others but it wasn't only you know
wasn't only Dave Roberts it's just a
mindset of where dur where the analytics
department of respective front offices
are having influence on baseball games I
know that we're a results-based sports
society so we look at Kershaw and say
well they should have started Kershaw
I'm not sure where you stand on it I'll
get your opinion I'll give you mine but
Darvish got roughed up again Kershaw
looked good should they have started him
Kershaw from the outset no 2020 right so
Kershaw you know not having his first
start was terrific the 11 strikeouts and
just absolute domination in Game one not
so much in the in the game 5 so I would
I really thought you Darvish after his
clunker in Houston that he was going to
be better than the inning and two-thirds
that he did in Houston yeah and it
wasn't I mean right from Jump Street
gave up a couple runs and then the big
blow by George Springer and all of a
sudden you down five zip and in a World
Series game that's a huge hole you know
yeah in hindsight yeah let let Kershaw
start with it Dave Roberts think he
could get four solid and I can't believe
I'm saying this for it would be absolute
disappointment if I started and coach
floorings of any game but for Darvish to
not get through to quick hook but when
you give up a two-run Jack and now
you're down by five that was that was
too much for the Dodgers to to overcome
yeah I think it's ridiculous to all of a
sudden now knowing what Kershaw did and
then say well you should have started
you know Darvish is an all-star this is
why you acquired him this is why the
Astros acquired Verlander for these
moments he didn't step up and either
start but I can't sit here and go yep
they should have had Kershaw in there
because if Kershaw starts Game seven
gets blown up then people say why would
you start him Darvish was on full rest
there and so I
I'm not buying into that I did want to
ask you this though the tipping of the
pitches at least the report that Darvish
was tipping his pitches did you notice
anything with Darvish the only this is
where I always thought not every pitcher
is insecure to begin with and I always
you know stealing signs and everything I
did I had multiple signs with nobody on
base but when you get a pitch when you
make a good pitch meaning let's say your
secondary slider a curveball and it's
off the plate and you see a guy after
two fastballs inside and he doesn't he's
not fooled he's not out in front on his
front foot he's balanced and he's taken
and he's seen all the way those are
indicators that you say wait a minute
I mean that was it that was a that was a
2-1 slider slightly off the plate three
four or five inches and you took it like
like nothing so that that would be my
red flag um I didn't know I guess I
wasn't watching as closely up until you
know I read I guess the same stories
that you were reading mm-hmm but
something was up because listen he's not
a bad picture you mentioned an all-star
and they brought him over to solidify
behind Kershaw and it just you know he
just didn't stay didn't do it his Brewer
Lander Hall of Famer you know I'm gonna
say yes even though his body of work
total body works not there yet he's 188
wins you know he's got this I got the
got the MVP
I really thought DP that you know his
start if he if he had if he had picked
that Jack Morris start yeah you know in
games game six I'm thinking or Randy
Johnson kind of start I would say Justin
Verlander will be a Hall of Famer I
don't know if he's if he's a lock solid
guy right now but he's he's been one of
the best pitchers in the last ten years
other astro fans at the airport there is
there they're looking a little Hollow
it's a happy hangover you know that
feeling you know that feeling a couple
times oh just a couple only twice yeah
hey safe travels back always great to
talk to you enjoy the offseason Thank
You al
you're welcome to keep that's a lighter
Major League Baseball Network former
major league pitcher on a couple of
World Series titles pitched for Toronto
and in the Marlins for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]